ce matin le commissariat de mantes a
reçu la visite du maire amer qui après
une première pensée pour le policier
blessé hier soir laisse éclater sa
colère aussi contre l'auteur du titre
la deuxième pensée bas vers les 44 1999
nantais qui vont souffrir de la présence
de salopards amante et j'en profite pour
dire que si ces 44 1999 personnes
veulent bien aidé les forces de police à
ce qu'on le trouve à le maire s'en
réjouira au val fourré on ne sait pas
d'où est parti il était 21h 15 hier soir
à se plaindre ou trois policiers de la
bac la brigade anticriminalité des
yvelines contrôle cinq jeunes qu'ils
soupçonnent de détenir du haschich pu
regagner leur voiture c'est à ce moment
qu'une détonations résonnent dans la
cité l'un des policiers s'écroule touché
au visage ses collègues l'évacuer
aussitôt
direction le commissariat l'hôpital une
agression de trop pour certains
habitants du quartier
avec ce coup fourré les voit bien que ce
contrat mais tout ça on a trop fait
c'est grave
j'ai parce que la carte et commence à
peiner à entrevoir beau succès pour
cette protéine
devant cette inquiétude le préfet line
rassurer les souligner le caractère
isolé de l'agression ne remet pas en
cause la politique que nous développons
en matière de sécurité qui repose sur la
prévention la dissuasion et la
répression
c'est l'occasion pour moi d'affirmer
très clairement une fois encore qu'il
n'y a pas de zone de non droit dans les
nippes et les cinq zones contrôlées par
les policiers au moment du feu ont été
mis hors de coupe
le sous-brigadier blessé a été opéré
dans la journée la balle entrée par la
pommette droite s'était logée dans le
coup entre la trachée et la colonne
vertébrale mais ses jours ne sont pas en
danger